oh hello there it's me Cal Smallwood the
interim host of biographics and today
we're talking about Christopher Plumber
s Decades of excellence and as with all
videos here on biographics this one is
based on a script submitted To Us by a
member of our writing team that being
Larry holsworth you can follow on the
social media links below which are on
side my own if you fancy doing that and
while you're down there you really nice
if you could like leave comments with
feedback or suggestions and subscribe
for more content like this normally I'd
ask that at the end of a video but
analytics say the earlyer in a video I
asked that the more like while to do
it in 1965 the musical film The Sound of
Music adapted from the Broadway play of
the same name appeared to huge
International success the film's
popularity LED it to surpass Gone With
the Wind as the biggest box office hit
of all time and reaffirmed the super
stardom of singer actress Julie Andrews
he also Ved the hio unknown lead actor
Christopher Plumber into the front rank
of film Act actors unknown that is to
mainstream film audiences by 1965
Christopher Plummer was well-known and
highly regarded stage actor having
earned considerable plaudits for his
performances on New York's Broadway
London's West End and his Shakespeare
festivals and repertoire in the United
States Britain and Canada his career
which eventually spanned over seven
whole decades led him to winning best
actor awards for theater the Tony award
film The Academy Award and television
the prime time Emmy Award the so-called
Triple Crown of acting today Remains the
only Canadian to be thus decorated his
performances displayed A diversity
seldom match ranging from traditional
Hamlet and King Lea to the Klingon
General Chang in Star Trek the
Undiscovered Country as Chang he
observed that Shakespeare should be read
in its original Klingon in stage film
and television he portrayed historical
figures such as the Duke of Wellington
Kaiser vilhelm II and actors such as
John Barrymore the billionaire JN Paul
gsy and television correspondent Mike
Wallace he also portrayed Charles
Dickens roard Kipling the Roman Emperor
Commodus the Conquistador Juan pizaro
and many other too numerous to list but
I did scroll through his IMDb page to
find the more shall we say forgotten
roles of his career which I'll discuss
towards the end but on with the scripts
yet he became largely known and
connected with his role was Von trap a
role he frequently spoke of
disparagingly calling it and I quote a
bit like flogging a dead horse
eventually he came to regard the film
and his role in it more fondly though he
did ask the guardian in 2018 and I quote
once again don't these people ever see
another movie is this the only one
they've ever seen compared to his body
of work the question does beg an answer
but we have to start as we often do at
the
beginning Christopher Plumber was born
in Toronto Canada on December 13th 1929
and was Christ with the imposing name of
Arthur Christopher or plumber his
maternal great-grandfather had been Sir
John abber the third prime minister of
Canada his father father who worked as a
stock broker and securities analyst left
the family shortly after his birth and
Christopher and his mother lived in her
family's estate in ceville a province of
Quebec located in Montreal Island an
only child Christopher studied piano
along with schoolwork with an eye on a
potential career as a concert pianist as
a child living in the Abbott family
Mansion Christopher Plumber enjoyed a
life which included the best schools an
indulgent mother a staff of servants and
private tutors he also grew up speaking
both French and English becoming fluent
in both the clarity of his English
dialect led many to assume he was
English in later years something no
doubt helped by his numerous roles in
Shakespeare plays and was raised by an
airdale plumber would later write
somewhat wistfully most of his
companions during his early years were
cousins and the dwindling staff of
servants and their children in his
autobiography in spite of myself plumber
described his encountering the urges of
puberty with the assistance shall we say
of a member of the servant staff who he
identified only as Madam moiselle he
explained that madelle vanished from the
home shortly after their still largely
innocent Tri was discovered by one of
the several aunts that frequently
attended the family home it was a
different time back then I suppose
plumber described the large contingent
of women in the home as and I quote a
combined force that was to say the least
intimidating in such an atmosphere
plumber grew up enjoying things like
tennis parties for more te's at 5:00
p.m. and listening to and making music
music of the beautiful kind with mad
Melle apparently he became engrossed
with the theater and acting fascinated
by the great actors of his day
especially John barimar gradually he
developed the acting bug himself and
began attending acting classes in school
CL was 18 when he was first cast as edit
person in a reporter production of
Lachine INF finale it was his first of
many unpaid roles and just Pro tip for
creators out there don't take unpaid
roles do not work for exposure as the
old saying goes people die of exposure
one thing of note about this role though
is that plumber was assigned an
understudy an understudy who was a
fellow Canadian actor by the name of
William Shatner yes that's William
Shatner which formed a friendship which
lasted to the end of plumber's life
in the late 1940s PLO began taking roles
as a professional actor that is to say
he was paid for appearing in there in
1952 he relocated to the city of
Hamilton British Bermuda where he
appeared in several roles at the and I I
always assume this was a word but it's
my first time encountering it the
bermudiana theater while in a production
there plumber was spotted by Edward
Everett hton an American actor director
and producer hton eventually persuaded
the young Canadians to take a role in
the play Nina which had been held by the
actor David nen when the play was on
Broadway though reluctant to leave
Bermuda for a winter time Road
production plumber eventually relented
by January 1953 plumber was ready for
his Broadway debut and it came in the
form of the play the Star Cross Story
the play opened and closed the very same
night when it was threatened with a
lawsuit for plagiarism so not exactly
the most auspicious start to her career
I should say though though Christopher
had nothing to do with the lawsuits the
closing did leave him in New York
midwinter out of work with no prospects
so Bermuda once again beckoned by Autumn
1954 he was back in the United States
touring on Broadway and then appearing
in several cities he toured with a play
as an understudy to American film and
theater star the awesomely named terrone
power the following year he enjoyed his
first Broadway hit saring in the lck
alongside Julie Harris who won a Tony
Award for her performance reviews of
plumber's role were uniformly positive
and though he followed that success with
an undeniable flop in Night of the orc
he soon rebounded appearing in the P
surprise winning play JB by AR Bo mcle
directed by Alia kazin Plum would
receive his first Tony Award nomination
for best actor in his role in JB he did
not win though the play did win the Tony
for best play of the year and kazin won
an award for best director plumber chose
to live in hotels while in New York and
became a well-known Dennis and the
various HTS popular with actors and
directors in the city New York was then
the center for television production as
well as Live Theater the reviews of
plumers onstage performan has Drew the
attention of several leading television
producers and though some actors looked
upon the newly burgeoning media with
disdain plumber was not among them
plumber entered the realm of Television
accepting roles and appearing in several
Anthology programs these included craft
television theater the Alcoa hour and
General Electric Theater and similar
programs in 1958 he appeared in again
with Julia Harris in the television
adaptation of the play little Moon of
Alban his performance earned him his
first em a nomination though he did not
win the award we would later so go
him in the early days of his acting
career and throughout most most of the
1960s Christopher Plumber carried the
reputation of shall we say enjoying life
on a level above what others were in the
bars and restaurants of New York Los
Angeles London Toronto and wherever else
he happened to hang his hat while his
career was still young his reputation as
a heavy drinker with a propensity to
chase women called some directors and
producers to question hiring him to
appear in their Productions though
plumber's professionalism at work always
served to reassure them while filming
inside Daisy clover in 1965 with Natalie
Wood plumber first expressed surprise at
the hospitality B which remained open as
long as filming continued throughout the
day often opening at 9 in the morning
soon he was availing himself of its
content he also wrote of his longing for
Natalie Wood during filming and he found
a competitor for her affections in the
form of Frank Sinatra yes that Frank
Sinatra who according to pluma was then
filming on an adjoining Sound Stage
Sinatra reportedly spent an inordinate
amount of time on the set of inside
Daisy Clover always with Natalie to Plum
his own suarin while in New York he was
a regular at the famous Algonquin Hotel
bar a frequent visitor the actor
Hangouts including sard's 2 and other
Manhattan watering holes among his
drinking and dining buddies were
Lawrence Olivier husband and wife Jason
rabar and Lauren B David N Rex Harrison
Richard Burton Peter OT and other
leading liks of the stage and film of
the day so he was wasn't exactly just
rolling with the plebs we should say
according to plumber his drink of choice
during this period was Scotch along with
fine Champagnes and other wines he also
developed a reputation as something of a
Gourmand enjoying fine dining especially
French cuisine he also enjoyed his
Personal Pleasures preferring through
the 60s to travel to and from Europe by
ocean liner that still pled the Atlantic
on schedule voyages though considerably
slower and more expensive than air
travel they offered the pleasures he
came to expect during his time off stage
or away from the cameras speaking of
which he married three TI the first two
actress singer Tammy Grimes in 1956
together they had a daughter actress
Amanda plumber who would be his only
child the marriage ended in divorce as
did a second to actress Patricia Lewis
in 1970 he married for the third and
final time to Elaine Taylor whom he
called Fu so her name would have been F
plumber f plumber she remained his wife
traveling companion and personal
assistant for the rest of his career
providing a calming presence to the
formul rambunctious Playboy unlike many
actors of his day plumber was
inordinately careful to ensure that his
enjoyment of Life shall we say did not
have a negative impact on his work
though he was not so circumspect when it
came to his own private life by his own
admission during his first wife's labor
with that only child he left to find a
bar and drink later saying coward that I
am I'm afraid I couldn't take it anymore
and left his womanizing and drinking
contributed to the end of both his first
and second marriages as he freely
admitted later in interviews despite
this he never completely gave up
drinking stating that during his third
marriage he limited himself only to Wine
his third wife also prepared the French
cuisine he loves so much at their home
in Western Connecticut which became
their American Bas far from the likes of
Hollywood in the taverns of New York as
he would later say she can cook a French
dinner that tastes like a French dinner
but isn't as fattening and this isn't to
say that plumber gave up the Finer
Things in life just that he indulged in
them more selectively after that point
reportedly traveling first class
whenever he could and always being seen
wearing custom May clothes from sevil
row and similar
[Music]
establishments in the late 1950s PL
began filling LS in his performance
schedules by appearing at American
Shakespeare Festival held in statford
Connecticut in 1956 he appeared at
Stratford Shakespeare Festival in
Ontario making his debut there in
Shakespeare's Henry V in the title role
as his repertoire of performances grew
so did his professional reputation
plumber was noted by his fellow actors
as well as directors stage hands and
critics as never failing to be courteous
polite and prepared and thoroughly
professional at least while working in a
profession known for having it share of
pronas plumber stood out for his
unfailing dedication to his craft and
fellow performers moving back to
Shakespeare plumber played the title
roles in Richard III and MC Beth the
pivotal role of mirio in Romeo Julia and
leontis in Winter's Tale to name just a
few including some performance at the
Globe Theater in London he received the
London evening standards Award for best
actor in the year 1962 who performance
as King Henry II in Becket the preceding
year with the Shakespeare Laurels firmly
at his feet he returned to Broadway in
1963 appearing as the conistor Juan
pizaro in the play The Royal hunt of the
sun another prais winning performance
under his belt while playing pizaro
Plummer suffered an accident on stage it
became a life-threatening Health crisis
pizaro was an epileptic and in a scene
in which the character suffered a
seizure the actor fell to the stage
severely injuring his right knee though
the injury swell to and I quote the size
of a tennis ball plumber continued the
play which required him to fall over two
more times the next day the entire right
side of his body was in serious pain an
examination by the hotel doctor revealed
a blood clot in the knee had led to a
pulmonary embolism which had reached his
left lung somehow miraculously missing
his heart had this clot entered his
heart it would have been in all
likelihood fatal understandably he
couldn't continue in the role and the
plays up to then successful run began to
draw smaller and smaller audiences
during Plummer's hospitalization as his
understood he performed the role his
Broadway run ended before he was
released from hosit Hospital which just
goes to show like the level of respect
he commanded even with a general
audience he followed his successes on
stage and television with an appearance
in the film the fall of the Roman Empire
in which he portrayed the Emperor
Commodus and just as an aside for
anybody out there who hears that name
and thinks why why do I know that
particular Emperor's name and that is
the role wahen Phoenix played in
Gladiator we'll bring it back to the
fall of the Roman Empire the film The
Epic and L Stringer reviews from critics
as well as his professional reputation
drew the attention of Robert Wise an
American director intent on bringing the
successful Broadway musical The Sound of
Music to the Silver Screen wise approach
Plum who though he had his doubts about
the script nonetheless accepted the role
of George Van Trum opposite Julie
Andrews as his housekeeper Nani Maria he
would long regret this
decision the Broadway musical The Sound
of Music and its film adaptation purport
to tell the story of the formation of
the trap Family Singers their opposition
to Nazism and their eventual flight from
their Austrian Homeland to freedom in
America the musical takes shall we say
considerable liberties with the facts of
their story Captain Von trap was much
older than plumber's character appeared
in the film he was far less austere and
a lover of Music in his household Marie
did not introduce the children of which
there were actually 10 rather than the
seven depicted to music nor did the
family Escape aided by a Convent by
hiking over the Alps of the movie
portray they just traveled by train to
Italy before leaving to the United
States which no doubt annoyed plumber
who is said to have researched his role
and the story quite thoroughly as well
as was prepared by hiring a vocals coach
and taking singing lessons when he found
out that his singing was to be DED by
another actor he was Furious to say the
least he later told the guardian and I
quote I'd worked on My Singing for so
long but in those days they'd have
someone trained who would sing through
dubbing he found the resulting story to
quote once again awful and another quote
sentimental Plummer said of his role and
I quote one final time the only reason I
did the bloody thing it was so that I
could do a musical on stage on film for
years following its release he would not
utter the film name in interviews or in
person referring it to it simply as that
movie or on occasion S and M again it
was a different time so despite his well
publicized misgivings over the film and
his role within it The Sound of Music
made Christopher Plumber a major
International Film star after years of
struggling to establish himself on stage
as a serious and dedicated actor he
achieved near overnight success in a
vehicle of which he disapproved despite
his overwhelming rejection of the film
and true to his character he did remain
friends with both Julie Andrews and
Robert Wise for the rest of his life
years later writing his Memoirs in spite
of myself plumber said of the film which
he refers throughout the book as SNM
which is admittedly very very funny the
film belongs to Julie of that there is
no doubt it's her movie Her Triumph he
also described f a sudden urge of Pride
that i' been a part of it while
attending a screening for a children's
Easter party as a favor to a friend he
gave all the credit for the film success
to Robert Wise and Julie Andrews and
ascribed its ongoing popularity entirely
to them rather than himself the success
of The Sound of Music created a demand
for plumber as a film actor which
allowed him to command large salaries
for roles he selected largely at his own
Leisure he selected film roles with an
eye for how their Productions would
affect his stage roles in the years
which immediately follow a Sound of
Music he appeared in several films in a
widely diverse range of roles with
filmed in Europe and the continental
United
States plumber's decision- making
process during this period was to select
roles that allow him to Showcase his
skill as a character or supporting actor
and he appear appeared in several such
roles throughout the 1960s and '70s for
example in 1969 he appeared in the
British war film The Battle of Britain
which used an ensemble cast of Mostly
British actors there was a Canadian
plumber was a noteworthy exception in
1970 appeared as the Duke of Wellington
opposite Rod stiger as Napoleon in the
War epic waloo neither film was
particularly successful moving on he
Diversified his portfolio by portraying
roard Kipling in a small role supporting
Shawn conry and Michael Kane in the man
who would be king he followed up his
performance as Sherlock Holmes in a 1979
Murder By decree he also had a major
role in The 1975 the return of the Pink
Panther and despite achieving some
success in films he continues largely to
focus on stage in London and New York as
well as in Native Canada he plays spies
and Nazis writers and musicians soldiers
and adventurers preferring character
roles to Leading Parts he continued to
perform in numerous roles in the plays
of William Shakespeare in the 1980s his
frenetic Pace began to slacken somewhat
at least in film in 1982 he revived
Shakespeare's orell on Broadway playing
the villainous lgo and supported by Jame
old Jones Kelsey gramar and Diane week
rave reviews from the New York critics
LED two full houses and plumber took
home another nomination for best actor
Tony Award for his performance he lost
to Roger re in Nicholas nickelby you'll
get there plumber you'll get there spoil
as he does but you'll get
there in 1997 Christopher Plumber
received his second Tony Award for best
actor his first for a dramatic role for
his role as John barimore in the
Broadway play barimore plumber credited
the award to the Ghost of John barimore
which he claimed inspired him nightly
plumber gave credit to the spirits of
several of the historic personages he
portrayed during his career including
Leo tlsty Kaiser willhelm II and rard
Kipling he also wrote of hearing ghostly
voices in homes he owned at different
times during his long career especially
in a house near Los Angeles where he
lived with his wife for a time in the
early 1980s whether he was inspired by
the spirits or not his film roles had
yet to achieve the levels of critical
Acclaim he received for his stage
performances and it wasn't until 2009 he
received a nomination for the best
supporting actor off Oscar for his role
as Leo tuloy he did not win in 2011 he
received the Oscar for best supporting
Act of his performance as an elderly man
coming out as gay in beginners when he
won he self- depreciate equipped to the
Statue where have you been all of my
life at the time he was the oldest actor
to ever win a competitive Oscar he
received a third nomination for his role
as Jay pauletti in all the money in the
world plumber stepped into the role
after Kevin spacy had completed filming
and you know Christopher Plumber was
widely loued for stepping into the role
so seamlessly turning re-shoot that
realistically could have taken weeks if
not months just a few days just a credit
to his professionalism and skill as an
actor as an elder Statesman of the stage
he continued to perform Shakespeare at
statford occasionally rewriting lines to
benefit the Innovative approach he took
to some of his roles he performed as
king Le depicted a king as having
suffered a stroke prior to the events of
the play the role Drew critical Acclaim
other perhaps less well-received
projects that plumber nonetheless lent
his considerable talent and the cache
his name carried to include and these
are the ones that I research search
myself and I'm very excited to share
them with you now National Treasure
starring Nicholas Cage a crappy 2001
Dracula movie in which he plays van
heling opposite of all people Gerard
Butler as the titular vampire lord and
also the probably the wrong of his
career was in 2015 when he appeared in
the animated lesser known film pixes
where he played the role he was born to
play King pixie lesser known roles he
played um is it Charles Muntz in the
film up he also reprised the role in a
Disney connect game for the Xbox 360 so
a long and varied career we should say
also in the 21st century he received
Emmy nominations for his performances in
nurenberg the money changers for which
he won and onor Golden Pond for which he
was reunited with Julie Andrews he was
actually scheduled to play the title
role in a film version of King Leah in
2021 that we died before project began
production speaking of which Christopher
PL unfortunately died in his Western
Connecticut home on February 5th 2021
age 91 Accord to reports in some some
media that cause of his death was
complications from a form which had
occurred some two weeks earlier his
manager of more than 40 years described
pluma as and I quote one more time an
extraordinary man who deeply loved and
respected his profession with great
old-fashioned manners self-depreciating
humor and the music of words he was a
National Treasure who deeply relished
his Canadian Roots although no longer
the oldest person to win an acting Oscar
with Anthony Hopkins achieving that
distinction in 2021 he remains the
oldest to have ever been nominated
receiving that nod for all the money in
the world in 2018 at the age of 88
despite all the accolades plumber chose
to remain humble in his 2008
autobiography which have already quoted
from previously he led the chapter which
discussed the sound of music with a
quote from the American actor Doug mccla
watching The Sound of Music mccla out is
like being beaten to death by a hallmart
card such was the self- depreciating
nature of one of the film stage and
television's greatest most prolific
performers of all
time so I hope everybody out there found
this video to be educational informative
and entertaining I certainly found the
script to be all three of those things
and if you think so too you can go let
the author Lar Hallsworth know and the
links you can find below also down there
are links to my own socials my own other
projects Wiki weekends and fact theme
with K Smallwood you can leave a like
leave a comment with suggestions and
feedback for future videos and as always
subscribe for more content like this and
go out there and have the day you all
deserve also just watch more movies I'm
a big proponent of the idea of watching
movies that you either don't think are
for you are are generally considered to
be bad or just very average I'm a huge
proponent of the six or seven out of 10
just because helps just broaden your
horizons like even if the movie isn't
that good it it will always have value
in teaching you what you do and do not
like and just yeah someone who greatly
enjoys um consuming and enjoying
discussing in media always going to be a
person who says go watch more movies
however bad you think they are
Cheers